[Music]
from Peter Berg director of three
separate films about Mark Wahlberg
fighting to stop an American Tragedy
though maybe that was more Mark's idea
comes a comedy that dares to imagine if
Will Smith was an emotionally fragile
celebrity who hit people for teasing him
Hancock
[Applause]
return to 2008 a simpler time for the
movie business when Marvel had just put
out a low budget take on one of its
b-tier characters and [ __ ] Superman
was an idea for a story not a whole
genre in this big budget Studio film
that doesn't cater to International
audiences
for women
or children why do you have an eagle on
your head this guy's like a little
talking machine huh how about you
thickness goggles oh stop crying punk
ass go ahead would you want a cookie
fell on my face foreign
[ __ ] a superhero cursed to live inside
his own CinemaSins video look at the
train why
[Applause]
he's got Superman's powers but instead
of Clark Kent's personality he's a drunk
lecherous poem and his Kryptonite is
white women further away you get from me
the better you're gonna feel you'll
start getting your powers back working
to save Hancock's image is Rey a PR guy
with a big idea for Corporate America
your new TB drug mikaden we would like
for you to give that product away for
free when that obviously doesn't work
he'll try to rehab Hancock's image
instead maybe I can't change the world
but I can change this guy's life with
one weird trick that lawyers hate go to
jail people take you for granted you
know the public will be clamoring for
you in this Latham of John through
America's prison system that just kind
of ends because the movie has nowhere to
go but up its own
oh God
prepare for a third act twist that turns
an otherwise okay comedy into a complete
train wreck as Rey's wife Mary is
revealed to be a super being okay I was
I was very strong at
who's also Hancock's twin lover sibling
thing sisters don't kiss Brothers the
way you kissed me last night whose
Powers turn off when they're close to
each other eventually it's never
happened this fast before and they keep
reuniting to fall in love and fight
battles throughout the Millennia summer
for PC 1850. but now he has Amnesia you
remember anything
setting up the Epic finale showdown
between two god-like Immortals and Three
Goons in a hospital hallway
think that the budget ran out or they
just had invented the third act Sky beam
yet
so enjoy a film that can't quite decide
what it is a raunchy violent comedy
a drama about two Immortal lovers
separated by FaZe you two are faded to
be together or a salute to timely local
news broadcast notoriously publicity shy
Hancock felony destruction of property I
asked my fellow angelinos for their
patience and understanding meanwhile
crime is still on the rise confirmed
that the prisoner Uprising we are
waiting for the latest news in this
Blockbuster they try to create an
original anti-hero that audiences love
from scratch but you can't expect to get
everything right the first time right
Vince he'll figure out eventually say my
name
story
sad boys for life
the Old Guard I do love your father but
he's more like a pet to me what is this
accent all of them I want you to break
into the vote you'll find three-quarter
ton pallets of small bills inside 30
million dollars and how conservatives
viewed Disney movies
on red
Norwegian
I was Legend
dude no one signed up for your little
Charity symbol are you just the guy who
defaced the moon I get in trouble for
that yes
I need Dragon Sword power now
if I'm the only customer and I order
soup then technically everybody is
ordering soup
chickens make ideal pets